let's just jump to the first story from
cnbc twitter permanently suspends
trump's account
they say the company said in a tweet it
made the decision due to the risk of
further incitement of violence
saying after a close review of recent uh
tweets from the from real donald trump
account
and the context around them we have
permanently suspended the account due to
the risk of further incitement of
violence
the suspension accounts to a ban trump
can no longer access his account
and his tweets and profile picture have
been deleted trump had 88.7 million
followers prior to a suspension
institutional accounts like potus and
white house are still active so
what if he tweeted through at potus
something ridiculous
why wouldn't he you mean
i hope he does still has access to
twitter maybe and he has the potus
account it's at po you know potus they
would suspend it until biden
got inaugurated and then they'd
reinstate it yeah
they say it's a step twitter has
resisted taking for all of trump's
presidency
while president barack obama was the
first president to use twitter he mainly
used the institutional potus account
and did not rely on his uh on it as
heavily as trump has to get his message
out
trump used his personal twitter account
to stoke supporters
and even make personal change personnel
changes before they can even make it to
the press release
yeah you know what it was this allowed
trump to bypass the media and they hated
him for it yep now i'll tell you
we got a lot of questions here this is a
historical record the things that the
president had been tweeting
but before we bring that up and those
issues let me tell you donald trump
i cannot believe the biggest mistake
made and i don't necessarily blame him
he's an old guy
you know he's not he's not social media
savvy he is pretty savvy for his age
and i'm not trying to disparage you know
people who are older
he could have at any moment tweeted out
to
88.7 million people follow me
on parlor follow me on mines follow me
and anywhere else
and then he could have had those 88.7
million choose to go somewhere else in
fact
just by posting on any of these other
platforms many people would have said
what did he say where did he say it
let's go check it out the media would be
forced to cover it he didn't do it
now there are reports that the donald
trump has joined parliament this
according to fox news's sean hannity
parlor is currently being hugged to
death as they say what it basically
means is
so many people are flocking to parlor
that the traffic is kind of overloading
it making it slow and hard to use
i've had no problem logging well i've
had a little trouble logging but once i
got logged in
seemed like everything was fine so they
must be dealing with it but
something trump could have done a long
time ago now i guess we should just
start by talking about the historical
precedence of
jack dorsey and mark zuckerberg and
these tech ceos having the ability to
tell the president you cannot speak to
the american people well why is it that
an
avalanche of bans happen every time it's
just like are
is there communication happening between
them
is it social pressure like what do you
think is really going on here i think
they're all cowards
and then when one network says we have
to remove this
all of the rest of them go now now it's
safe for us to do
another thing we really have to
understand here is that this is a
transition of
power speech is power and if you're not
able to talk to your
supporters if you're if you have a whole
political party that right now
is voiceless that's a major step
in in what i believe in an extremely
wrong direction the last time we had
censorship the major censorship story
was of course the hunter biden story
it was wrong they were wrong about that
story they
censored it for i believe in my own
opinion political needs
and then it came out that oh yeah the
hunter biden story
was true after the election after the
election
time after of course joe biden you know
i don't even want to we've got to be
careful with our language here uh
after the election was called for joe
biden the story popped back up in the
media yeah
yeah this is i mean in my opinion 1984
just happened today
uh and wonder woman 1984. no not that
was that a coincidence
unless of course it was joe biden who
grabbed the dream stone and said i want
to be president the whole world's on
fire
a lot of this is being done allegedly
for your safety but let's not discuss
you know let's not discuss it let's not
lie about this is essentially
political and cultural dominance that's
exactly what it is
it was this whole system was abused
before and and this is
the continuation of that abuse of power
i'll tell you what i said it's uh
a major political party demanding
of massive multinational billion-dollar
corporations
the removal of their political
opposition it's a cultural coup
they are removing their opposition from
the discourse period
and it's been happening for some time
and this is the most dramatic escalation
we saw back in what was it 2018 when
they got rid of like jones and like milo
yiannopoulos
yeah and they they targeted certain
people
that was you know a slow uptick now it
is the most dramatic
people high profile personalities not
just on the right are reporting they're
losing thousands of followers
we can't actually see the the level by
which this purge is happening
the censorship is bigger than just the
president and it could be even hundreds
of thousands of people
yeah i mean uh i i think i just lost a
thousand followers on twitter myself but
we can't say that we didn't see this
coming i mean just even
what was it a couple weeks ago we were
talking about this very topic
and we talked about will donald trump be
banned and we both agreed and said yes
donald trump's going to be banned well
actually our timeline was wrong because
we said after
the inauguration i disagreed yeah i said
they would lose too much money
i thought that they you know for like
you know early on
i thought they would totally do it
because they hate the guy
but then i started talking to people who
said you know look at look at their user
base it was in decline before trump so i
think someone mentioned twitter stock
went down when they banned trump like
it's probably going to plummet in my
opinion i'm not you know i don't own any
stock on twitter
but i imagine it would go down because
trump made that platform
so after the us capital moment that's
when i knew
i was like oh they're gonna they're it's
gonna be you know it's gonna be neutral
it didn't take a genius
to understand that this was going to be
their crisis this was going to be the
event that they use that they're going
to
exploit and that they're going to
purposely inflate
as a major threat and that's exactly
what they're doing they're doing it very
disingenuously
and they're they're doing it on a bed of
lies and that's the another important
aspect here
nothing good is done based on a huge
foundation of lies
so we have to understand that this huge
major move this huge
transition of power all is happening
under
fake pretenses and uh it's it's it's
worrying
they are engineering echo chambers yes
this is
a global echo and radicalization and
radicalization
and see the studies show evidence
actually on both sides it is
true that social media can cause you to
go down a rabbit hole of ideology but it
is also true
that communication social media is the
only way you can become de-radicalized
so there's evidence on both sides but
the overwhelming evidence
shows that there's there's massive
blowback
of the censorship you're shutting down
dialogue which is our only option
other than taking our only option for
de-escalation
is communication is being able to hear
people out and not putting people in the
fringe more people are going to be
on the fringe and more people who are on
the fringe are only going to become
friends
it's not the fringe anymore it's when
when they start banning
your run-of-the-mill conservatives who
voice their support for the president
you don't have to like the president you
can disagree with them these are not
like you've got a lot of regular people
and what you're doing is we i think we
talked about this before bill it's
actually i think i mentioned we talked
about it on joe rogan
you take a regular person and he gets
arrested for pot
and you put him in prison with hardened
criminals and you are
guess what happens to that person yeah
you know you take some young person
who's like you know
first charge they go to prison and now
they're around all the you know burglars
robbers
murderers and that's what you're doing
you're putting people in these
environments
yeah it's 70 million it's 70 plus
million 75 million plus people that
voted for
donald trump and again last night i i
said on this show
the censorship is about to reach levels
that we have never seen before we are
here today and
again it's only going to get we're sorry
and i cut you off no that's okay man
brandon strzok i don't know if you're
familiar he does the walk away campaign
hashtag walk away his campaign was
banned
off twitter this is like a kind-hearted
good dude and
they he's the kind of guy that if you
bust him for pot and put him in prison
with a bunch of criminals
he's going to get twisted and so they
banned him they banned his entire
facebook page campaign of i don't know
50 000 people all
people all his uh um organizers and
employees have now been banned off
twitter or on facebook
it's insane yeah heavy-handed insanity
this is this is another thing books are
being unpublished
there's even democratic committees
calling for no-fly lists
for individuals who are a part of the
right i mean this is a new level
of authoritarianism that i never you
know you know
like it's here it's real i remember i
had a conversation with
joe rogan with jagade and jack dorsey
on um the joe broken experience and um
i think i remember that at the end of
the episode i said if you keep doing
this
it is going to get really bad in this
country what you are doing
and then what did we see all throughout
this year and what did we just see in
the capitol
and then i said i'm going to build a van
and they all laughed and everybody
laughed i got emails they're like oh you
crazy dude you're gonna go build a van
nothing's gonna happen ah where are we
now yeah
so here's what here's what i think i
think we're not looking at a linear path
of escalation i think we're looking at
an exponential path of escalation
when we went from a bunch of people in
dc
many of them breaking into the capitol
which i think was ridiculous and stupid
people are now dead a cop was bashed
over that's just
insane but many of these people walked
right in there's videos where the cops
open the door
and and say something one cop says that
he agrees with their right to protest
and as they waltz on in some of these
people are bewildered but listen
i saw that and i thought to myself that
the initial reaction will be
overwhelmingly negative now i think
because of the mass purge
you're gonna start seeing an
overwhelmingly positive reaction from
people who feel like they've been
excised from society so there were a lot
of people posting on twitter
that they felt that their opinions were
watered down out of fear of being banned
well don't worry twitter just did the
hard work for you
now these people have been kicked off
after they said they followed the rules
not everybody did a lot of people being
banned are like
you know advocating for some crazy stuff
but there are a lot of people
who are saying things like well i
shouldn't say anything you know
my and some there's tweets saying i
think we're all holding back
they get banned now what okay i guess
there's no point anymore
so here's what i think i think after
what we saw
the immediate reaction was insane
you've got politicians like corey bush
and aoc demanding the expulsion
of republicans that supported trump
simon and schuster a major book
publisher announced they would
they're breaking their contract with
senator josh hawley
he challenged them saying he's going to
sue him this is
i mean it's it's dramatic escalation
where the culture is being split
people are being demonized at an ever
increasing rate and now we've come to
the point where
you actually have joe biden going on tv
and likening two sitting u.s centers
to nazi propagandists this level of
demonization and dehumanization
is the precursor to drama to to
horrifying things
i'll i'll spare some of the more
hyperbolic words but
when you look back at history historical
civil wars the start of major wars
this is the kind of thing that happens
just before and what do you think is
going to happen
when uh when the incoming president
announces the wall street journal
reported this
sweeping new domestic terror laws joe
biden's announced
while calling sitting republicans
likening them to you know nazi
propagandists
what do you think that demonization will
lead to the demands for expulsion do you
think that the republicans are going to
be like we're so sorry democrats
no the these the supporters are being
forced into a totally different echo
chamber reality
where people are angry we had david
cross
tweet that he wanted blood whether
whether it was a joke or whatever
you don't know that's the problem don't
no don't care sarcasm doesn't work on
the internet i guess not in the text
it's similar to with sacha baron cohen
being you know
crazy yeah it's like don't you
understand that comedians need to be
protected too this is coming for you
yeah people don't understand people on
the left you're going to be affected by
this sooner or later
as soon as your paths cross the
establishment and the talking points and
the narrative that they want to push i
don't care who you are
it could even happen at blm blm still
hasn't you know i don't think
had their meeting had their meeting with
biden last i saw in a few couple days
i don't know if i may stand corrected
here but anyone could stand in the way
of this
big unaccountable totalitarian monster
monster that holds one of the biggest
sacred powers in the world
one of the things that makes america
great more than any other place in the
world
is our free speech once you get rid of
that once you
limit that once you stop allowing people
the ability to freely communicate with
each other
we are in uncharted territories where it
is ripe for
abuse so the heartbreaking thing tim
that you kind of
alluded to is that regular democrats and
republicans
cannot even speak to each other they
you know families are being torn apart
there is there is a
tweet from a young woman ratting out her
mom
for being at a protest i think the
precursor protest not the one at the
capitol but the night before
saying this is my mom here's her name
here's my dad and then the mom got fired
that's crazy stuff they're they're
breaking up families do you see the usa
today uh article where they put out 29
pictures of people that were at the
capitol
if you can help us find their names and
phone numbers give us their information
and
help us find these criminals remember
remember when andy noe
just tweeted out this individual has
been arrested
and the left said he is creating kill
lists and doxxing people
and they started smearing him and
attacking him and now media across the
country is putting up people's names
saying find them
find them sure criminals people accused
of many crimes
by all means send your tips but i'm
talking about the double standard
andy no would simply be like the police
arrested this individual
and then they would attack him for it
then you get the media coming out now
saying we don't know who these people
are what they were doing in fact
what if some of these people were
credentialed journalists elijah schaefer
for instance
of blaze tv a reporter was getting
attacked relentlessly by people on
social media
i'll admit some of his tweets were a
little bombastic
he had one tweet where he called it a
revolution okay dude chill
but he is a credentialed member of the
press who works for the blaze tv he got
banned by facebook
probably because of these hit pieces and
then only after i think glenn
came out and said what you know and
complained about it they reinstated him
that's the danger of publishing a face
and then saying find him
because we all saw what happened after
the boston bombing on reddit
when all these good-hearted redditors
said we must find these criminals
and end up doxing random innocent people
that's the problem
so you have andy no here's the persons
whose picture they
were arrested on this charge and they
threaten him and they attack him and
they accuse him of doxing and he's a
villain he's a bad guy
now the media is totally on board
totally okay with going even beyond that
and saying identify these people and
they're doing it they're doing it
they're doing
you know they're publishing names and
here's the problem there's no actual
empirical data or evidence that shows
what they're doing
is making the world a safer place in
fact the opposite and so what we're
actually trying to do is on a on a 10
year basis
a b test a b test
a strategy and see who can have a higher
rate of d radicalization here's the
thing we are going to
be able to prove that we have a higher
rate of de-radicalization on minds
because you cannot de-radicalize someone
that you have just banned their rate of
de-radicalization will be
zero and i i say this all the time
if if you have somebody who who does bad
things and then one day they come out
and they apologize accept their apology
i mean maybe not the second or third
time you know it's up to you
but if someone's like you know i
shouldn't have been doing those things
please accept my apology you say
yes please come join us doing the right
thing
if you don't they'll say that i have no
opportunity but to go to anyone who will
be willing to accept me
so if you've got someone who makes hate
speech and they're you know they're
going on twitter and they're saying
rabble rebel and offensive words
and you decide the best way to get rid
of them is to ban them the only place
they can go
is to where everyone agrees with them
and they're allowed to
you know say whatever they want if you
truly don't want them to believe these
things the best thing you could do is
talk to them like that woman from the
westboro baptist church
that was on twitter right people started
reaching out to her and then she
flipped from being a member of this this
church to being like hey that was wrong
i should have been saying these things
people really changed my mind and were
nice to me but i don't think they want
this
this is this is what i think you know i
i in my opinion i think
they want the violence ted cruz came out
and said
we all need to put the anger aside and
come together and aoc responded by
saying no
you should be expelled from congress
okay well that's just going to make
things worse
he literally said can we put the anger
aside and come together and you attacked
him for it
to score brownie points on the internet
or whatever i guess so then ted cruz has
no opportunity whatsoever to come
together with anyone
so they won't and then his followers
won't either and then the
hyperpolarization continues
cnn getting nine million you know
viewers their biggest ever
and you have this handoff between cuomo
and don lemon where they're scoffing and
insulting and berating and degrading
instead of being calm and serious even
shep smith get that off the tv we're not
showing this that's not true
that is not how you handle conflict
these people have no idea what they're
doing yeah the only answer to bad speech
is
good speech and if you start to limit it
you again
putting people on the fringe and you're
starting to expand it i remember during
the kind of infancy of the internet and
kind of growing up in that day and age
and thinking
this is absolutely incredible this is an
amazing tool that allows people to speak
to each other
and then i realized just like any kind
of great technological advancement it's
a tool
it's a weapon it's a sword and it has
blades that go both ways
and just like it has the potential to
help people it has the potential to
hurt a lot of people and now we're
seeing a huge backswing i remember
i remember warning about this all the
way back in 2008 i have we are change
videos on my channel warning in 2008
saying hey
they're they're already starting to turn
out turn on the boilers the water is
starting to get warm here
and there and look what they did here
they did it very methodically they did
it very slowly they didn't just ban
everyone all at once
they started starting to actually now
now oh it's like a weight
we're seeing the first bubbles in that
pot now
we're starting to turn a little bit of a
different color it's too late
yeah here's what i hear here's what i
want y'all to understand what twitter is
doing what facebook is doing and youtube
is doing
is actually diminishing their ability to
control anything and will result in
substantial chaos
if there are 100 people in a room and
you have rules and some of those people
break the rules
then you can slowly start to remove some
of those people or you can compromise
and say here's what we'll accept and
here's what we won't
and what happens is if
you decide to ban 10 people now you have
10 people in one room and 90 in the
other and you have no say of what those
10 people are doing
we're going to come to the point where
twitter has half of the people in one
room and half in the other
and then it's going to be two equal
sized rooms with no control over the
other side
no ability to influence or de-radicalize
or communicate at all
and that's when the clash happens and
the chilling effect you're talking about
friends who are just deleting all their
posts because they're scared they're
going to get banned now
and i mean the the the psychological
impact
that it has just on the people who are
allowed to be there and snowden has
brought this up with
you know how surveillance impacts your
your your
brain and how you want to communicate he
said today is a major turning point
in history that says yeah go ahead sorry
no yeah but it's just the the chilling
effect in the
the mass sort of social
psychological implications that this has
like in
in in the herd mentality when
everybody's posting like either in
support of it
or against it but like at the end of the
day all that matters is data
what actually works and they're not
published
they know this they have to be able to
see that what they're doing is making
things worse and
they they have to know this there
there's no way
they've seen it before they've banned
people before they've seen the reaction
and they have to you know what it is
maybe they don't have the data from
external platforms but i'll tell you
this
anyone with a brain can take a look at
the bannings they did
and then the chaos that ensued yesterday
and be like hey remember two years ago
when you banned all these people
how did that work for you now they're on
parlor
and you have no control at all you've
given it up
you've said go do your thing thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you